على الرغم من أنني أبدو صغيرًا وبريئًا ،
يمكنني حقًا إطلاق العنان لكل شيء أسعى إليه
فقط ، ولا أسمح لهم بالتقليل
من شأني ، أريدهم أن يخافوا على هذا اللوح وأعلم أنه يمكنني فعل ذلك ، اسمي
آنا ميلر ، أبلغ من العمر 11 عامًا  سنة وفي
الصف السادس
وأنا في بطولة العالم للشطرنج
للناشئين للأشخاص
ذوي الإعاقة ، لذا فإن إعاقتي هي
تكوّن العظم غير الكاملة مما
يعني في الأساس أن لديّ عظام هشة ، لذلك من السهل
بالنسبة لي أن أنكسر عادةً ما أفعل ذلك مرة واحدة في
السنة.  تعرف على عدد فترات الراحة التي
حصلت عليها حتى الآن ، ولا أسمح لذلك بتحديد من
أكون أفعله وما يمكنني فعله
يحدد من أنا نوعًا ما لا تدع ذلك
يمنعنا من القيام بهذه الأشياء
ونحن "  لن ألعب أبدًا لعبة كرة القدم لكنها
أيضًا لا تريد على أي حال أنني
وقعت في حب أي شخص يمكنه لعب
الشطرنج ، البنات والأولاد ذوي الإعاقة ،
إنها تحب استراتيجية ذلك ، ويمكنها
التفكير في بعض الخطوات للأمام بطرق
لا يمكنني القيام بذلك.  هي البطولة الأولى
التي لعبت فيها حيث كان الأطفال فقط
الإعاقات ، هذه هي البطولة الوحيدة
في العالم للاعبين الصغار
ذوي الإعاقة ، لدينا 16
لاعبًا من العديد من البلدان المختلفة ،
أي حالة طبية مسموح بها
لأختي التي تعاني من شلل دماغي ، يتعين على أمي
حملها في كل مرة لا تستطيع الجلوس
على الكرسي لا يمكنها الجلوس  في المنضدة في
المنزل ، لا يمكنها فعل الكثير من الأشياء ، لذلك
لديها متسع من الوقت فقط لتعتقد
أنها فتحت الباب لعالم آخر
، أعتقد في الماضي أن الناس
كانت لديهم فكرة أنه إذا كان شخص ما يعاني من إعاقة جسدية ،
فثمة خطأ ما  مع
عقولهم ، لم يكونوا
أشخاصًا أذكياء ، وهذا بعيد كل البعد
عن الحقيقة ، ما نحتاج إليه هو
توفير النظام لهم ليكونوا قادرين
على اللعب ، هناك مدرب يجلس هناك
تتحدث إلى المدرب وتسبب لنا في
حركة من أجل  هي مثل Bishop g7 أو أي
شيء لا يبدو أنها
على اتصال بالعالم ومن ثم
تكون قادرة على إنتاج هذه
الحركات وترى أنها تلعب بشكل جيد جدًا
ما رأته يمثل لشخص ما على قيد الحياة  في
غرب آسيا ، يا رفاق ، الشيء المفضل هو
مجرد مسرحية عندما أقوم بحركة جيدة ،
يجب أن أعترف أنها تبدو لطيفة جدًا ، ولكن
حتى إذا خسرت لعبة ،
يمكنك الخروج من الغرفة وأنت تفكر في نجاح باهر أن هذا
كان ممتعًا حقًا.  رؤية أشخاص آخرين من
ذوي الإعاقات مثلي ، أعتقد أن
ذلك يجعلني أشعر حقًا أنني
لست الوحيد الذي على كرسي متحرك أو
أحاول التنافس مع أشخاص آخرين ، فهم جميعًا
يعانون من أمراض صعبة ، ويواجهون جميعًا
صراعات يومية للقيام بأشياء بسيطة
في المستقبل  إلى مكان يشعرون فيه
بالقبول التام ، ولكن أكثر من أي شيء آخر ، للاستمتاع
فقط عندما يتعلق الأمر بالشطرنج ،
قد لا تعمل ساقي جيدًا ولكن
عقلي سيفعل ذلك ، لذا أعتقد أن الناس
لا يقللون من شأننا لأننا قد يكون لدينا
أنواع معينة من العلاج الطبي  الظروف التي
لا تعني أننا لا نستطيع العمل
الجاد لأننا لسنا شجعان فقط نشر
الكلمة حول لعبة الشطرنج للجميع